hey guys my name is Jess and ETS
Valentine's Day Eve so it's kinda start
swiping right that's not your thing
here's what's happening in gaming first
up Nintendo have revealed more details
about what's happening with the free
splatoon to demo coming to switch the
global test fire event will run from
March 24 to 26 during designated one
hour windows Nintendo revealed that up
to 10 switch consoles will be able to
connect over the newly announced tool
and play feature up from supported eight
players via local wireless connection
however the feature requires the
consoles to be in their docks and the
extra tube players will only be able to
spectate the Nintendo switch arrives on
march three and splatoon two will arrive
sometime this summer next up the
physical pc version of Hammer was to has
been canceled for the US but is still on
its way to Europe three four threes
community manager Brian Gerrard
explained on Halo Waypoint our retail
plans have shifted and Microsoft has
made the decision to focus the release
of the physical retail version to europe
only microsoft partnered with THQ nordic
to create the physical version of halo
wars 2's pc edition gerard added we
apologized to any customers affected by
the change in our retail plans and thank
everyone for the continued support as we
look forward to the release of halo was
2 for xbox one and Windows 10 PC hello
Wars 2 will be available on Xbox one
physically and digitally and will be a
play anywhere title in related news 3
for 3 confirmed halo wars 2 will not
have map making tools and they also
revealed the game's complete list of
achievements finally it appears resident
evil 7 score was toned down for Japan
warning there are spoilers ahead it so
beware as spotted by Kotaku censored
gaming has highlighted some of the
differences between the u.s. and
japanese release of the game
particularly in the scenes involving
deputy david anderson for example in the
US Edition he is added with a shovel and
his head put into a fridge for the
player to discover charming in the
japanese version however the ill-fated
law man's head stays attached to his
body and the
head in the refrigerator is replaced by
a simple photo you can check out the
full video and all the changes in our
story on gamespot that is everything
I've got for you today do head to gain
spot for a sniper elite for review and
our tips on how to beat nearest toughest
buses I will see you again tomorrow